well two things we spend more on the
military than the rest of the world
combined so we are without question the
premier military power and that has a
lot of implications for one thing it
tends to distort our industry it means
that we spend a lot of time and effort
and research developing kind of
specialized products and technologies
that we actually don't want to use we
hope we will never use and that have
very little application for our wealth
producing capacity and but yet it soaks
up engineering talent and scientific
talent but more important than that is
that because of our hegemonic security
role we we tend to find ourselves in a
position in which number one our leaders
our president for example when our
president wakes up in the morning and
the first thing that he does is to look
at his national intelligence report now
when the president of Singapore wakes up
in the morning the first thing he does
is to look at how much new investment
Singapore is getting that day so the
mind share of US leaders is very much
focused on geopolitics ah and at any
particular moment the need for us to
have support from our allies or even
from from countries with whom we have
difficult relations well tend override
our economic interests a good example of
President Obama was in China in November
and he stated in a press conference that
the United States
would attempt to assist China in
developing and building its new regional
commercial jet now when I heard that I
kind of shook my head and I thought wait
a minute
we make jets we make commercial jets
we're so we're we're supposed to export
something and airplanes is one of the
things that we export why are we helping
China developed us I and then I realized
that well the president wants who Jintao
to help him out with good North Korea he
wants them to help him out with Iran he
wants them to help him with global
warming so there's all these issues and
he makes an economic concession in order
to get that or if you go to the website
of the Polish Embassy in Washington
you'll see that the Polish Embassy
reporting that it has been able to
achieve the offset production of about
eight billion dollars worth of high-tech
US military equipment an offset means
that the poles buy American fighter jets
and in order to induce them to do that
the u.s. agrees that we will transfer
the production of a large portion of the
jet to Poland so in effect we pay Poland
for the privilege of defending it and so
this is geopolitical priority emphasis
tends then to take away any thought of
promoting our economic interests